io sono qui oggi per raccontarvi una
storia della racconterò in forma di
storia che vi racconto io ma potrebbe
raccontarvi la stessa storia un altro
dei 100 compagni di viaggio che ci sono
stati in questa storia qui questi
compagni viaggio sono qui stasera a
parlare alte di qcer marco zamperini
gianluca dettori non c'è ma c'è con noi
virtualmente riccardo luna e altri 100
che hanno fatto questa storia è che
hanno preso parte questa avventura che è
stato un successo ma ancora non è un
successo come vi spiegherò adesso cos'è
un agenda digitale
in due parole è una strategia per
digitalizzare una nazione una regione un
comune ma è anche un modo per cambiare
il mondo quello che noi viviamo tutti i
giorni
ve lo spiego facendo vedere questa
storia anche con gli occhi di google
france se voi utilizzate google france
con google trends potete vedere quello
che davvero la gente cerca quello a cui
la gente davvero interessata
se vedete la storia di agenda digitale
con gli occhi di google france vedete
che una cosa che nasce a gennaio del
2011 si impenna poi a qualche il colpo
carsicamente riappare scompare per un
lungo periodo tutta l'estate e riappare
a novembre dell'anno scorso e poi a il
picco proprio pochi giorni fa intorno a
ottobre ma cos'è questa storia di agenda
digitale
allora però raccontò proprio come storia
nasce sotto casa di zamperini e non
all'inizio lo chiamiamo brodo parti
perché con una strana a cena ci troviamo
intorno a un tavolo un po di esperti
diciamo di innovazione digitalizzazione
poi i giovani rappresentanti di tutte le
forze politiche stranamente il tutto
intorno a quel tavolo davanti a un buon
brodo corroborante il giorno prima dello
iab forum luglio affoga una specie di
evento importante che fa un po da di
riferimento alla chiusura per tutti
quelli che sono
i numeri i problemi le opportunità del
mondo digitale e davanti a quel brodo un
unica considerazione facciamo tutti
quanti ma possibile che non ci sia un
minimo comune denominatore per mettere
insieme una proposta che sia al di là di
schieramenti quindi c'erano persone di
destra di sinistra il centro pensatori
un po ognuno con una presenza e diciamo
anche un suo consistam all'interno di un
partito diverso non esiste un minimo
comune denominatore allora da lì noi
partiamo e cominciamo questa avventura
però prima di dirvi quale d'avventura
perché è importante
all'epoca l'italia era l'unico paese
vedete bene in quella mappa fatta dall
ai più che insieme alla libia non aveva
una strategia per la digitalizzazione
ma perché è importante una strategia per
la digitalizzazione se lui paragoniamo
la francia all'italia un paese molto
simile
mi scuso mi spiace che non si vedono
bene i numeri con con questa immagine
però in francia l'economia digitale su
quello che ruota intorno a internet vale
più o meno il 32 per cento della pil in
italia il 2 per cento del pil in francia
vale quanto il settore dell'energia in
italia quanto la ristorazione e questo
ha dei riflessi sia perché a noi quello
che serve ce lo dicono tutti i giorni ce
lo dicono tutti i giornali ci serve
crescita ci serve crescita del pil e ci
sarei anche occupazione perché quello
che fa internet tutta la tecnologia oggi
a creare occupazione in 15 anni in
francia un paese molto comparabile al
nostro ha creato al netto 700mila posti
di lavoro
lo stesso periodo da noi se ne sono
creati solo 320 mila quando noi ci
lamentiamo dei posti che mancano la
disoccupazione giovanile in realtà un
paradosso perché continuiamo a parlare
sempre di settori maturi che non ce
l'hanno mai posti di lavoro per giovani
che ne sono i settori innovativi per la
nuova tecnologia quelli che possono
crearli invece per per giovani
l'altro pezzo del problema e questo si
chiama competitività si chiama
competitività e guardate soltanto il
grafico che li alla vostra sinistra quel
grafico mostra qual è stato l'andamento
2000 e oggi dei costi per produrre un
unità di prodotto astratta in italia la
linea più in alto in alcuni altri paesi
e in germania
allora nello stesso periodo noi abbiamo
guadagni a doppia o meno un 12 per cento
di posti costa di più produrre in italia
nello stesso periodo in germania nostro
competitor diretto rispetto alla media
dell'europa non risparmiano il 20 per
cento
se guardiamo all'italia rispetto al meno
di tutti gli altri paesi ue
vediamo che il problema è ancora più
grosso perché da noi non è il problema
di distribuire la torta per prima di
creare la porta l'italia che
tradizionale né un prodotto un paese che
con tanti mali in realtà è molto
produttivo cioè riesce a produrre anche
in condizioni molto difficili e un paese
che dal 2000 in poi ha perso il 2000
sostanzialmente iscritto finisce eccede
cede in termini di produttività quindi
il nostro profeta crolla e da 130 che
siamo all'inizio finiamo a 110 perdiamo
in meno di dieci anni il 20 per cento in
termini di competitività
questo è il problema perché non cresce
il pil perché è piccola la torta e non
riusciamo a come dire farla crescere
vado molto rapidamente per spiegarvi
altro pezzo della storia la storia
continua così ci si vede da tutta italia
riteniamo un manifesto si vede a firenze
il manifesto esce comprando una pagina
sul corriere della sera autofinanziato
ognuno di noi ha ammesso 100 euro
la firmano persone dello spettacolo da
jovanotti fiorello carlo massarini
amministrato dei gatti di società
importanti e comincia a creare un po di
dibattito se una presentazione a roma
pochi giorni dopo cross il commissario
europeo per l'agenda digitale
appoggio la nostra campagna ma convegno
allo iulm un convegno in assolombarda
poi scadono i 100 giorni che ci eravamo
dati per avere una risposta del mondo
politico comune e trasversale a questo
come un sacco di proposte e qualcosa
comincia a cambiare se voi guardate e la
stagione delle elezioni comunali
non c'è amministrazione di sinistro di
destra che non abbia un pezzo del
proprio programma dedicato a l'agenda
digitale ma tutto era nato da un brodo
sotto casa di zamparini
ora tutta l'estate passa e non succede
granché ma durante la presentazione del
programma di governo al senato
il professor monti parla esplicitamente
di uno degli impegni quello dell'agenda
digitale del nuovo governo passa però in
realtà un po di tempo prima che qualcosa
succeda nel frattempo la prima regione a
darsi un'agenda digitale della lombardia
poi seguono altre bisogna aspettare per
un nuovo episodio di questa storia fino
a marzo a marzo nasce l'agenzia digitale
del decreto crescita uno mi è ricreata
la cabina di regia
poi c'è confindustria digitale è nata
nel frattempo proprio per dare un nome
alla rappresentanza del nuovo cappello
all'agenzia digitale e creare su italian
digital forum con grande passerella di
nomi altisonanti e dei ministri poi c'è
un primo decreto legge che istituisce
l'agenzia c'è un bando pubblico per
scegliere un direttore generale
poi viene approvato una serie di
provvedimenti che portano in qualche
modo a muoversi alcuni provvedimenti
dell'agenzia digitale viene pubblicato
soltanto due settimane dopo è nominato
un attempato maturo esperto giovanotto
di 63 anni a capo di questa agenzia
e se tutto va bene per natale verrà
convertito in legge il decreto varato
una lunga storia molto complessa come
detto un successo perché
mannheimer ha fatto una ricerca a pochi
giorni fa presentata proprio un paio di
settimane fa come dice che oggi degli
opinion maker la 85 per cento sa cos'è
l'agenzia nel padon l'agenda digitale ma
della gente comune solo il 37 per cento
sa che cos'è un agenda digitale ma
perché l'agenda digitale oggi è ancora
più importante per tre ragioni che vi
dico molto rapidamente la prima prima è
iscritta nella storia la storia dice che
i grandi cambiamenti tecnologici grandi
cambiamenti culturali arrivano a
grappoli c'è stata l'epoca della
rivoluzione industriale c'è stata
l'epoca della creazione del industria di
massa questa è l'era dell'informatica
quella della st che parte negli anni 70
con immersioni del chip si può datare
prima o dopo non importa quello che
importa che tutte queste rivoluzioni
arrivano sempre con la stessa struttura
creando delle bolle quindi la bolla
della new economy perché che studia
storia è normale c'è stata la bolla dei
telefoni libero dei telegrafi la bolla
delle automobili ogni nuova occasione
nuove opportunità crea delle bolle ma
poi cambia il mondo con queste regole
prima c'è il cambiamento la tecnologia
volete visto tante idee fino adesso
tecnologie bellissime non tutte le
trovate nella vita di tutti i giorni
perché il mondo della tecnologia sempre
più veloce cambiamento economico viene
dopo
abbiamo delle comiche dato su due forze
quelli che finanziano il cambiamento
tecnologico quelli che lo comprano e lo
adottano la cosa più difficile il
cambiamento istituzionale ci vuole molto
più tempo a quelli che solo la classe
dirigente quelli che hanno la
responsabilità di fare le politiche per
recepire questi cambiamenti per recepire
il fatto che c'è una leva in più per
trasformare la società per cambiarla per
modificarla
la seconda ragione per cui questa
battaglia non è vinta
e molto importante invece insiste è
questa un libro di management
purtroppo per tradizione queste sono le
cose che posso citare bisogno la ricerca
fatta su tantissime aziende che hanno
avuto tanto successo e poi
improvvisamente non hanno
io ho avuto successo e cos'è che avevano
fatto avvia di manager cacciati le
accuse c'è per cento meno in comune una
cosa almeno in cui si sono trovate in
difficoltà come noi oggi come paese nel
nostro complesso siamo in difficoltà
perché è un fatto oggi dell'europa non è
degli stati uniti non è dell'asia non è
il sud america
cosa hanno fatto sono tornati alle
origini hanno fatto quello che aveva
permesso loro di avere successo e questo
è stato il loro e loro si sono cambiate
radicalmente le cose si devono fare cose
ha radicalmente diverse questa è la
terza e ultima ragione in cui finisco
problema è che la tecnologia cambia le
persone non cambiano allora
l'opportunità quale ogni cambiamento
crea la possibilità di risolvere
attaccare problemi che noi abbiamo già
davanti che già conosciamo con modi
nuovi con soluzioni diverse
se dovesse fare una sintesi è il modo in
cui vengono risolti i problemi l'italia
sono nuove leggi più complesse più
articolate poi vanno a inserirsi su
altri leggi ancor più complesse ancora
più articolati ecco quello che mi auguro
per il futuro dell'agenda digitale e qui
vorrei voi ministe per quello che ognuno
può fare proprio pensare a un futuro in
cui non sono più leggi diverse la
soluzione ma un modo di applicare le
leggi in modo di applicare le leggi a
problemi che sono conosciuti tutti quei
problemi che noi conosciamo bene
l'evasione fiscale la mancanza di
trasparenza nell'amministrazione
oppure i costi della sanità tutto un
altro utilizzando la tecnologia per
avere soluzioni diverse e quindi effetti
diverse che si continuiamo a fare le
stesse cose abbiamo fatto nel passato
difficilmente queste cose cambieranno
dobbiamo fare cose diverse cose nuove
grazie per l'attenzione